in just hours OJ Simpson could learn if
he'll be released from prison and Nevada
proofed parole board is expected to
decide today whether to free the former
football star John Blackstone is outside
the Lovelock Correctional Center where
Simpson is being held John good morning
good morning well OJ Simpson will appear
today via videoconference from behind
these prison walls to ask for his
freedom
now with networks planning live coverage
and crowds expected to tune in it's
clear this will not be a typical parole
hearing one thought James Simpson not
guilty of the crime of murder more than
20 years after OJ Simpson became a TV
obsession his fade is once again
captivating the nation today inside this
hearing room in Carson City four members
of the Nevada Parole Board will decide
whether Simpson should be set free count
one conspiracy to commit a crime guilty
I spent more than eight years behind
bars for armed robbery and kidnapping in
Las Vegas after trying to steal sports
memorabilia he claimed was his but even
the prosecutor who convicted Simpson
thinks the former football star will get
parole I can't imagine him doing another
robbery at age age 70 I suspect that
he'll be on parole for a period of time
and you know if he messes up then he'll
go back to prison
Simpson's Vegas conviction was
considered a stunning fall from grace
for a man who couldn't seem to escape
the limelight we need to find him we
need to apprehend him we need to bring
him to justice from the moment his name
was linked to the murders of his ex-wife
Nicole Simpson and her friend Ron
Goldman the country followed his every
move as did hundreds of reporters myself
included it is not only OJ Simpson's
life that is coming under the media
microscope in an effort to minimize
media frenzy Nevada's parole board plans
to take the unusual step of issuing its
ruling within minutes rather than days
as soon as the hearing is complete
they will go straight into deliberations
complete those deliberations and return
right straight back and deliver those
the board will consider Simpsons
behavior in this prison his age in
employment history as well as testimony
on his behalf today he will be eligible
for release as soon as October 1st Norah
all right John thank you